half the time we see any of the Walking
Dead survivors on screen they're covered
in post-apocalyptic filth and zombie
sludge so when the real-life
counterparts clean themselves up and hit
the interview circuit there especially
stunning they're even more
unrecognizable in these adorable
throwback pictures from their youth
here's what the walking dead cast looked
like his kids Andrew Lincoln Andrew
James Clutterbuck hails from London and
showed an interest in acting in his
early teens he chose the stage name
Andrew Lincoln after studying at the
Royal Academy of Dramatic Art and
landing his first real gig in an episode
of a UK sitcom called dropped the dead
donkey it would be almost a decade
before he landed his second most widely
seen role to date as the lovesick sign
holding mark in Love Actually since
becoming sheriff Rick Grimes for the
walking dead Lincoln has shunned all
other roles Chandler Riggs just seven
when he first started packing heat to
battle the walkers Chandler Riggs is a
natural within the realm of the undead
it's also a been there done that
situation for him since his first role
was in the short film Jesus h zombie The
Walking Dead set was a homecoming for
him as he's a native of Atlanta Georgia
where the show is filmed Riggs is
keeping the horror theme going starring
in mercy in 2014 as well as the 2016
home invasion flick keep watching Norman
Reedus
after moving to LA and working as a
motorcycle mechanic Norman Reedus was
discovered at a party it wasn't long
before he landed a role in Guillermo del
Toro's mimic and the 1997 film floating
launching his career before the walking
dead he was best known for his role as
Murphy McManus in the boondock saints
Rita's original audition was for the
role of Merle Dixon but had already gone
to actor Michael Rooker show execs liked
him so much they created Barrel Dixon
for him not knowing the character would
become such a fan favorite Melissa
McBride in the early 90s Melissa McBride
landed her first role on an episode of
Matlock but she also worked behind the
scenes as a casting director you may
also recognize her from her appearance
as Dawson's slightly older lady in
Dawson's Creek McBride was chosen to
star as Carole due to her relationship
with the original showrunner Frank
Darabont who cast her in his adaptation
of Stephen King's the mist also in the
mist Laurie Holden who played The
Walking Dead's Andrea and Jeffrey deMunn
who played Dale
Stephen yet although he was born in
Seoul South Korea Steven Yeun and his
family moved to Saskatchewan when he was
a child this is the core of William I
have brought a picture that salutely Yun
studied psychology in college and his
parents hoped he'd pursue a career in
medicine or law and your parents were
not happy that you chose this profession
I know that my parents are Korean and
traditionally that first generation of
Korea Americans aren't too happy with
the little curveball that you throw them
he had an interest in acting though and
moved to Chicago to pursue his interest
in improv landing a gig with second city
before relocating to Los Angeles prior
to dead he had a number of roles and
shows like the Big Bang Theory and Law &
Order LA but his biggest break happened
when he landed the part of Glenn Rhee
which was only his second audition in LA
lauren cohan although she was born in
the US lauren cohan family relocated to
the UK when she was a teenager so that's
why she still speaks with the distinct
accent when she's out of character after
studying drama in college she launched
her career in the mid-2000s with films
like Van Wilder - and float she gained
more screen time as Bella in
Supernatural and a brief albeit
memorable stint on the Vampire Diaries
before joining the walking dead is
Maggie Greene Danai gurira born in Iowa
and raised in her family's native nation
of Zimbabwe Danai gurira participated
heavily in her school's drama programs
she later studied psychology at
Minnesota's Macalester College and
achieved her MFA at NYU's prestigious
Tisch School of the Arts Guerrera became
involved with the Broadway theater scene
as well and is still active in theater
her harrowing play about the Liberian
sex slave industry titled Eclipse was
recognized by the 2016 Tony Awards no
stranger to action Guerrera also won the
role of Akoya a Royal Guard and Marvel's
black panther Jeffrey Dean Morgan
Seattle native Jeffrey Dean Morgan has
made a name for himself in both TV and
film perhaps best recognized as
ill-fated heartthrob Denny Duquette at
Grey's Anatomy and through his recurring
roles in Supernatural Magic City and The
Good Wife The Walking Dead marks
ammoniacal new turn for Morgan's screen
presence as he previously been known to
play a relatively nice guy in most of
his major projects Michael Cudlitz
before he started rocking the
walking-dead shows most mean friendly
facial hair is Abraham Ford Michael
Cudlitz had a few memorable TV and movie
moments on Beverly Hills 90210 Band of
Brothers and Southland the latter earned
him a Critics Choice Award in 2013 since
taking on the role of the troubled but
beloved Abe porn Bisquick he tried to
make pancakes Cudlitz has continued to
work on the small screen
Navan recurring guest roles and ballers
and House of Lies during his ded
downtime Josh McDermitt on the walking
dead eugene porter might be
unintentionally funny but in real life
josh McDermott's entire career can be
attributed to his humor he got to start
by calling into a local phoenix radio
show before making a very brief
appearance on the comic competition show
Last Comic Standing he then moved into
acting on the failed pilot for rehab for
rejects and the quickly canceled sitcom
retired 35 before making a two-episode
appearance on AMC's Mad Men finally
McDermott landed the role of a lifetime
as The Walking Dead's resident mullet
the smartest man I ever met happen to
love my hair he said my hair made me
look like and not quote a fun guy thanks
for watching subscribe to our YouTube
channel to watch more videos like the
one you just saw and leave us a comment
to let us know which Walking Dead actor
is your favorite